well you know one of the main things I
did at the United Nations that I think
is so important is I did a book that
focused on the 193 company countries the
percentage of time they voted with us
and how much foreign aid we give them
yeah uh Chef can you tell us what would
be your approach to uh poultry based
dishes if you were to be hired to run
this restaurant listen one of the
biggest things I did over the last three
months is I did a book where I would
list
items available at different restaurants
oh oh okay but so like what would what
would the poultry dishes be here it's
just completely incoherent and by the
way she did a book containing
information anyone can just Google about
different countries and by the way it's
not even clear she actually claims to
have written it notice that she said she
did a book rather than I wrote a book